Speaker 1: Let's go.
Where else are we going to go?
Let's go to let's go to Jack from Belgium.
Let's hear from an international caller.
Jack, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hey, David, thanks for the go ahead.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Speaker 4: I've had two small questions today,
OK?
The my first question was whether you think
the main reason that the first hundred days
of Biden now seem good because everybody had
kind of low expectations after Trump instead
of well is actual accomplishments.
And I feel like his accomplishments have been
have been, of course, positive for the country.
But I just feel with everybody's expectations
this low, maybe that made him seem better.
Speaker 1: Beautiful.
OK, so I think that you're right to a degree,
but I would say my my grade for Joe Biden
for his first 100 days, which is, you know,
it doesn't really matter what the grade is,
but it's pretty good.
I think that it's about 90 percent what Biden
did and 10 percent that he had low we had
low expectations because of Trump.
So I agree with you in part, but I think that
if you actually compare Joe Biden's first
hundred days, I would say to any recent president,
Joe Biden has objectively gotten a lot done.
Would I like to have seen more?
Of course.
But I actually think it's mostly that Biden
has actually done things well.
Speaker 4: Right?
Of course, I've seen the positive things that
he's done, and I'm also happy with them.
So I would agree.
Well, and my other question was whether you
think he'll keep up the momentum until 2024
to hopefully get the second presidency, because
I'm I'm afraid that he'll slow down by the
end and not.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I'm thinking of this in a
two year sprint.
I'm thinking of what happens between now and
2022.
If in twenty twenty two Republicans take the
Senate and or the House, the dynamics for
twenty twenty four are completely different.
So rather than worrying yet about twenty twenty
four, we don't know if Trump is running, we
don't know anything about twenty, twenty four.
What we know is that in twenty, twenty two
there could be a complete change in the balance
of power.
I'm focused on these two years and I think
that for now Biden has three big things that
he's going to be continuing to work on, some
of which he announced that at his Wednesday
night speech.
So let's focus on these two years first.
Speaker 4: Of course.
Well, I think the House is pretty much what
I heard about a lot of gerrymandering is going
to happen with the Republicans, which is basically
going to give the House to the Republicans.
As far as I've heard.
I don't know which sucks, but.
Yeah, well, we'll see.
We'll I'm for that.
But the Senate is looking decent at least.
Yes.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, I in twenty nineteen,
I thought Democrats would not take the Senate
in 2020, but might take it in twenty, twenty
two.
They took it in twenty twenty and maybe they
can even build on the majority in twenty,
twenty two.
Speaker 4: Well I would really like to see
that.
I'd be very happy for that.
Speaker 1: Remind me, what part of Belgium
are you in.
Speaker 4: Antwerp.
I'm from Antwerp.
Oh right.
Speaker 1: Right, right, right.
Beautiful, beautiful city I've been.
Speaker 4: It's Oh nice.
Yeah of course.
Speaker 1: And I think I don't know if I asked
you this last time, as far as French fry sauces
go, what are your favorite sauces.
Speaker 4: I personally really like samurai
sauce.
It's very spicy.
It's got a good vibe to it.
I was like, so
Speaker 1: is it a ketchup?
Is that a ketchup based sauce?
Speaker 4: Well, it's more it's a whole bunch
of it's kind of like we've got cocktail.
It's like mayo and ketchup together with.
Speaker 1: Oh ok, ok, ok.
I like that.
Speaker 4: But I must say sorry as a Belgian,
the fact that so many Americans call them
French fries.
Speaker 1: I know, I know.
They're really they're Belgian frites.
Right.
Speaker 4: So I just wanted to point that
out.
Speaker 1: I know.
I apologize.
I made a mistake.
Speaker 4: OK, well, thank you.
And thank you for taking my call.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
All right.
Very good.
Thank you so much for the call.
Always want to be checking in with all sorts
of different people and we will check in with
more people momentarily.
If you're holding, don't hang up.
We're going to a quick break and we will be
right back after this.
Dealing with the paramount issues of our time,
including French fry doneness.
We've addressed sources.
We will address crispiness after this short
break.
OK, don't
hang up.